nos piden que resolvamos la siguiente
ecuación 2x cuadrada + 5 igual a 6x lo
primero que quiere hacer es pasar esto
de la forma estándar y cuando me refiero
a tener una ecuación de segundo grado en
su forma estándar estoy pensando en lo
siguiente hay que es cuadrada más bx más
c
igual a cero porque así es mucho más
fácil resolver una ecuación cuadrática
que verlo así y por lo tanto para pasar
esto igual hacerlo que es quitar este 6x
y para ello voy a restar de ambos lados
6x y que me va a quedar bueno del lado
izquierdo me queda 2x cuadrada menos 6x
más 5 y del lado derecho me quedan 6 x
menos 6 x se van y me queda igual a 0
por lo tanto ya está en su forma
estándar y bueno a continuación lo que
quiero ver es que esto no es divisible
entre 26 si es divisible entre 2 pero el
5 no es divisible entre 2 por lo tanto
factorizar esta expresión no se ve tan
sencillo como pensamos y es justo en ese
momento cuando se me ocurre que tal vez
la podamos resolver o completando el
binomio al cuadrado perfecto o
utilizando la fórmula general para
resolver
la fórmula cuadrática o la solución
general de ecuaciones de segundo grado
que nos dice que x es igual a menos b
más menos la raíz cuadrada de b cuadrada
menos 4 a cm y todo esto hay que
dividirlo entre 2 a que al final esta
fórmula pues recuerda que se prueba
completando el binomio al cuadrado
perfecto así que estamos haciendo lo
mismo y bueno pues vamos a resolver esto
me queda menos b pero en menos b es
menos 6 entonces me queda menos por
menos más me queda 6 más menos la raíz
cuadrada de b cuadrada es decir menos 6
al cuadrado lo cual me da 36 36 menos 4
por a por c 4 por 2 por 5 se vale en
esta ocasión 5 y a todo esto hay que
dividirlo entre 2 a pero a vale 2
entonces me queda entre 4 y bueno esto
es lo mismo que 6 más menos la raíz
cuadrada de 36 menos todo esto que está
aquí es 4 por 28 por 540 entonces déjame
ponerlo aquí 36 menos 40
entre 4 todo esto hay que dividirlo
entre 4 y bueno quiero que te des cuenta
que aquí adentro de la raíz cuadrada
tenemos 36 menos 40 lo cual me da un
número negativo menos cuatro y todo esto
hay que dividirlo entre 4 y en ese
momento me dice sal pero la raíz
cuadrada de menos 4 es un número
imaginario vamos a trabajar en esta
ocasión con números imaginarios y la
respuesta es que si quiero que
trabajemos con números imaginarios y
veamos que también son soluciones de las
ecuaciones cuadráticas y de hecho como
sacamos la raíz cuadrada de menos 4
bueno pues esto es lo mismo que 2 y
recuerdas cómo se acaba la raíz cuadrada
de un número negativo bueno para eso
utilizamos los números imaginarios es
decir la raíz cuadrada de menos 4 déjame
ponerlo aquí arriba quién era esto es lo
mismo que la raíz cuadrada de menos 1
por la raíz cuadrada de 4 y bueno de
creo que me estoy saltando un paso mejor
déjame ponerlo así esto lo mismo que la
raíz cuadrada de menos 1 por 4 menos 1
por 4 es igual a menos 4 y entonces
ahora sí separó la raíz esto es lo mismo
que la raíz cuadrada de 1 por la raíz
cuál
de 4 en la raíz cuadrada de 1 sur
principal es y no olvidemos a los
números imaginarios y la raíz cuadrada
de 4 estos por lo tanto todo esto se
simplifica en 2 y entonces me queda que
x es 6 más menos 2 y entre 4 y bueno
esto lo puede simplificarse dividido
tanto arriba como abajo entre 2 y me va
a quedar 6 entre 2 es 3 más menos y
entre 2 y bueno aquí ya tengo mis dos
raíces de esta ecuación recuerda que
cuando yo tengo una ecuación cuadrática
tengo dos raíces mi primera raíz sería
poner esto en positivo y me quedaría
tres medios más un medio de y tres
medios más y entre dos pero y entre dos
es lo mismo que un medio de iu o en su
dado caso la segunda raíces tres medios
menos recuerda que una es positiva y la
otra es negativa
menos un medio de iu y fíjate que aquí
ya lo tenemos en su forma compleja
estamos hablando de números complejos
donde claramente se ve cuál es su parte
real y cuál es su parte imaginaria así
que cuando esto ya tenemos nuestras
raíces de esta ecuación que queremos
solucionar nuestras ecuaciones que
existen los números
tres más y entre dos estas dos cosas son
iguales la podemos ver así o en dado
caso así y la otra pues la veríamos como
3 - y entre 2 2 destacando de aquí a la
izquierda esto es lo mismo que 3 - y
entre 2 lo único que estoy haciendo
separando esta expresión que tengo aquí
bueno pues a continuación lo que quiero
hacer es demostrar que en efecto estas
son las raíces a que me refiero lo que
quiero ver es que no nos hayamos
equivocado y sustituir el valor de x en
la ecuación original en la igualdad
original por nuestras raíces para ver si
se cumplen esta igualdad es decir estoy
buscando la comprobación de esta
solución y para esto lo que voy a hacer
es sustituir a x por mi primera raíz que
mi primer raíces 3 más y entre 2 y que
me queda 2 que multiplica a 3 más y
entre 2 lo voy a poner mejor así y esto
elevado al cuadrado si le sumo cinco
tiene que ser igual a seis veces x pero
x es 3 más y entre 2 y las 3
sustituyendo en la ecuación para ver si
realmente se cumple esta igualdad y
bueno como elevó al cuadrado me queda el
cuadrado del primero
más dos veces el primero por el segundo
es decir nueve más seis veces y más el
cuadrado del segundo el cuadrado de y es
cuadrada fíjate que lo único que estoy
haciendo es resolviendo este binomio al
cuadrado perfecto cuadrado de 39 más dos
veces el primero por el segundo seis y
tres por 12 6 por 16 y más el cuadrado
del segundo el cuadrado de iese cuadrada
lo cual vale menos 1 ya esto lo
dividimos entre 2 al cuadrado que es 4
ya todo esto le sumamos 5 tiene que ser
igual a 6 entre 2 lo cual me da 3 y a 3
lo tengo que multiplicar por 3 más y
tres por tres me dan 9 y 3 por y me that
3 y es decir todo esto tiene que ser
igual a 93
y bueno lo primero que quiero que veas
es que 9 menos uno se puede simplificar
y esto me da 88 6 y entre 4 y bueno a
continuación la tvc es dividir tanto
arriba como abajo entre 2 para
simplificar un poco esta expresión 8
entre dos me da 4 6 y entre 23 y
4 entre 2002 y 2 que multiplica y 2 que
dividen se van también y me queda simple
y sencillamente que 4 3 y ya esto le
agrego 5 tiene que ser igual a 93 y
bueno 3 y 3 si pagan estos dos se van y
solamente me queda que 45 es igual a 9
pero eso es cierto por lo tanto qué
creés tres más si entre dos si es raíz
de esta ecuación perfecto ya tengo una
de mis raíces y además la demostración
de que si es raíz la comprobación ahora
lo que me tengo que fijar es en mi otra
raíz tres menos y entre dos y quiero ver
si también es raíz de esta ecuación por
lo tanto voy a tomarme otra vez la
ecuación original con la que partimos 2x
cuadrada más 5 igual a 6 y ahora voy a
sustituir a x por 3 menos y entre 2 y me
queda 2 que multiplica x cuadrada es
decir 3 menos si entre 2 elevado al
cuadrado más 5 igual a 6x pero x lo
estamos sustituyendo por 3 menos si
entre 2 y esto a que va a ser igual
bueno pues primero voy a hacer lo mismo
que hice acá
voy a elevar tres menos y entre dos
elevado al cuadrado y lo que quiero que
te des cuenta es que arriba tenemos un
binomio al cuadrado perfecto otra vez
que por cierto hay que resolver 3 al
cuadrado es decir el cuadrado del
primero me da 9 menos dos veces el
primero por el segundo 2 por 13 6 por y
me da 6
y a esto hay que quitarle 6 y y después
menos y elevado al cuadrado es decir el
segundo al cuadrado menos y elevado al
cuadrado es exactamente lo mismo que y
elevado al cuadrado es menos 1 es como
cuando tenemos menos tres y tres
su cuadrado es el mismo y si quieres lo
podemos ver aquí - y elevado al cuadrado
es lo mismo que menos uno porque menos x
menos me da más y elevado al cuadrado me
da menos uno entonces me quedan nueve
menos seis y ya esto lo voy a sumar
menos uno pero más x menos el mismo que
menos entonces mejor 96 y menos 1 ya
esto hay que dividirlo entre el cuadrado
de 2 que es 42 al cuadrado me da 4
todo esto lo tengo que multiplicar por 2
y después sumarle 5 y esto tiene que ser
igual
6 entre 2 otra vez me da 3 esto lo puedo
simplificar un poco 3 y 1
estoy dividiendo todo entre 2 y me queda
3 x 3 9 y después 3 x menos y lo cual me
da menos 3 y bueno pues vamos a
simplificar la parte de arriba de todo
esto que tengo aquí
9 - 1 otra vez me da 8 entonces esto me
da 88 menos 6 y después voy a dividir
tanto arriba como abajo entre 2 y me va
a quedar 4 menos 3 y entre 2 así que
deje al ponerlo 4 menos tres y entre 2
recuerda que lo que estoy haciendo
sacando la mitad de arriba y sacando la
mitad de abajo entonces me queda 2 y
ahora sí 2 que multiplica otra vez y 2
que dividen se van de nuevo y me queda
simple y sencillamente 4 menos 3 y 5 4
menos 3 y más 5 tiene que ser igual
vamos con calma 4 - 3 y más 5 esto tiene
que ser igual a 9 menos 3 y 9 menos 3 y
bueno aquí está otra vez menos tres y
menos tres y paga
y 459 por lo tanto también paga esta
raíz 3
entre 2 también cumple que es una raíz
de esta ecuación cuadrática que teníamos
originalmente y es que aquí hay algo muy
importante si tenemos un número complejo
entonces su conjugado también es raíz de
esta ecuación cuadrática